Karin is in Tennessee my husband and I
are debt-free except our home but do a
lot of shopping online how does the
envelope system work when you shop
online what doesn't the envelope system
is not for things that you buy online
it's for things you buy when you're out
walking around if you're in the mall if
you're in the store but if you do
everything online you've got to have a
budget and that holds you to it I can
jump on every dollar and every dollar
calm make sure you've got your budget
going and all the envelope does is it
tells you if you're running out of money
in a category for those of you don't
know for instance if you're setting up
your food budget that's one you
generally some people buy it online so
we will do delivery grocery delivery and
that kind of stuff now but most people
still go to the grocery store so let's
put the amount of money we're gonna
spend the groceries on an envelope in
cash and go to the grocery store and
when the cash is empty that means you
quit buying and it makes you realize
when you're busting through a category
on budgeting and so that's what the
envelope system is and but all of this
is just a category it's all it is so the
every dollar app and if you're what if
you're sitting there you know in your
recliner getting ready to buy something
on Amazon Prime you jump over check the
app do I have the money in that category
to spin because I'm getting ready spend
money and if you don't then you don't
click Prime right you just move on and
do something else and quit impulse in
your butt off online but if you've got
the money and you want to buy something
I don't care buy it that's the point
you're just making your money behave
instead of wondering where it went
that's the whole process here so hey
good question good question